what they do bro how you feeling man I'm
very good it's a little hot in this room
I'm not gonna lie it's cool a little
toasty it's fun uh well look man third
album yes sir
we didn't have to wait as long for this
one
12 months
yeah it's been a year now yep I feel
like I feel like uh it's been I remember
the the last album release party Dave
Chappelle was there yeah he hosted it
that was it that was pretty big no
that's a bar yeah he did a great favor
for me too I asked him and then he said
easy money so Steve Urkel was there yeah
he was actually yeah I was in a joint
circle with Simba Steve Urkel and Dave
Chappelle in back backstage at the
pepper was it the peppermint Club yeah
it was the pepper yeah yeah a lot of
good people showed up to support killer
Roy showed up uh kids at work was there
yeah yeah like a lot of got a lot of
love from a lot of artists and people
how does the Dave Chappelle thing work
out like how do you guys become friends
first time you know what we got really
close during
um
the pandemic I will fly to Ohio to see
when he was doing those shows yeah
exactly and um he's just a really good
it might be the Virgo connection too but
um
not that I'm like a moon worshiper so
are you are you really into that I'm not
sure I'm not a moon worshiper what do
you worship God shout out to God you
know shout out to God the one but which
type of God though we're going Catholic
God Christian God baptism I'm a Baptist
I'm a Christian for sure okay but um
more so
um with Dave Chappelle like we just got
really cool because
um somebody I can always go to for
advice and he just real down to earth
like he's just a real one bro you know
so visiting him in Ohio like a town in
kind of the middle of nowhere it's in
the middle of time the thing covered
[__] paranoia yeah it was it was
awesome yeah so you guys just from there
just connected and it was like and you
know he's from Maryland too so it's it's
an easy thing